All right.
Hey,
what's going on everybody?
It's bill burr and it's time for the Thursday afternoon,
just before Friday,
Monday morning podcast and just checking in on you.
I'm just checking in on your week here.
And uh,
usually,
you know,
what do I usually do?
I usually sit here in my fucking pajamas.
I fucking,
you know,
give you a little half hour fucking bullshit to 12.
But it's payday,
right?
You don't need a full show.
You had probably half in the bag and a fucking El Torito at this point.
If you listen to it,
you shouldn't be driving.
But every once in awhile I do have a guest.
I do have a guest and today we have the Great Joe Rogan.
Hey fucking,
uh,
grand national champion at Taekwondo Sitcoms,
Star fucking reality show.
A commentator right across the board.
L Conner,
wild boar hunter.
I don't know what I fucking conspiracy theory.
Fucking whatever you want.
This guy,
he's his own fucking entity and he has a brand new killer special on Netflix
entitled triggered.
Please welcome Joe Rogan.
Thanks Bill Burns going on.
Long time coming through.
I know last time coming,
I'd love your show.
I have lunch one on mine a bunch of times,
so I know to be on yours,
but you're a big like interview guy.
I'm,
I'm like a fucking lunatic who just sits in the corner of his house and every
once in a while my wife walks by and I love the style that you do cause it's
very unique.
You know,
I've done a couple like that where answer questions and stuff like that,
but it's a very unique style of,
you know,
I think it lends itself really well to stand up and to developing bits too.
I just didn't want to deal with having to like book.
Like you're fine,
you're simple.
You okay,
come down to my studio.
Perfect.
You know what I mean?
But like I just didn't want it.
I saw what other people were going through.
Like,
oh,
I got an audition,
can we make it four o'clock?
And I was just like,
I don't want to fucking deal with that stuff.
But,
um,
but when I,
if you know,
if everyone could be a guest like yourself,
can I start with the elk thing?
Yeah.
Because I am fascinated with hunting.
I think it's bad ass.
I think everybody should know how to do it.
And in,
I'm not one of the,
I am an animal lover,
but I'm not going to be that hypocritical one that fucking eats chickens.
Then had the fucking beaks clipped off and they got the,
the roided out Mark McGuire breast plate and the tipping over the coops,
all that shit that you see.
And then I'm going to be like,
Ooh,
could you shoot a fucking pheasant or whatever the hell you're shooting out
there.
But,
um,
you,
I retweeted a picture of you got this.
What does it,
you said it was a 12 point or why don't you say six?
It's a six by six.
They call it a straight six.
So I said it means a big elk.
That was the,
I've shot three hours.
That's the biggest one by far there.
And one was monsters.
It was huge.
So what is the,
uh,
this is the thing that always fascinates me about hunting shows is the
nervousness and the whispering.
Before you take the shot though,
it's like,
okay,
there it is.
Relax,
exhale.
And just like,
if you miss,
I mean,
it's the fucking thing going to come running at,
you know,
it seems like because it doesn't,
I not to spook it because you have to have it
close enough for you to shoot it.
Depending upon how you shooting it.
If you shouldn't it with a bow and Arrow,
you gotta be real close.
You've got to be inside of 60 yards.
[inaudible] bad ass.
I shot one with the bow and arrow.
That one out there,
the big one I shot with a rifle dude,
a bow and arrow.
That's,
that's to me,
that's the Shit I saw Ted Nugent.
He shot a fucking bear,
you know,
which I could never do.
I fucking love bears is certain animals.
But you know what I mean?
Bears are interesting.
I've,
I've shot bears.
You shut up.
So I'll get you some bare sausage.
I can't eat bear.
I've shot three bears and I can't eat a bad,
the good.
And I knew about fares.
Delicious.
You're like a fucking sirloin.
Well,
we,
uh,
Philemon young got no tender and juicy.
Um,
I've always felt that about you,
Joe.
Thank you.
We think of bears,
I think very incorrectly because would the,
you know what the word a anthropomorphization means when you put human
characteristics and animals like Yogi bear and shit like that,
when you make them ride a bicycle at the circus,
we have this idea that bears are these cute things.
But where my friend lives in Alberta where I hunt,
they literally have to shoot them because they don't have any predators.
So bears don't have any predators.
And they just breed and the keep reading and then they decimate the Moose
population,
the elk population,
and they cannibalize each other.
That's the thing that most people,
they kind of handle it in house sort of,
but they eat babies.
That's what they do most of the time.
Eat Babies.
They eat their own babies.
The Chi of sliders,
black bear sliders.
Well,
why wouldn't you?
it's,
it's brutal to see,
you know,
we've,
we've stumbled across pause and stuff from a cubs with a male bores the double
though.
That's what the ones that when you just find a baby bear paw in the woods,
I mean the a party,
his soul has to just fucking die or cry out.
Like I,
that's something I never want to see.
It's very strange.
I guess I do have to admit though that uh,
bear hunting's not,
I don't like it as much as hunting other animals.
If I had to choose like what animal's tongue,
you can eat bear by the way.
And that's the only things that I hunt is what I eat.
Black bear.
Uh,
you can eat grizzly bear,
but they don't taste good.
Most of the reason for that because grizzly bears mostly eat meat.
They eat a few berries.
If you can find a grizzly bear that was just eating berries,
it would probably taste delicious.
They literally tastes like what they eat.
Like hunters tried to go after bears eat berries like a black bears in
particular in the fall they'll eat blueberries.
They called them blueberry bears.
Cause like as you were opening them up,
their fat is like a purple color and it tastes like blueberries and apparently
it's the most delicious meat in the world.
So without them realizing that they're already marinating themselves.
Exactly.
You guys wow.
Seasoning themselves.
But my all time favorite animals are elk.
That's,
that's the best.
They taste the best,
the best for you.
And uh,
he gave me that,
that elk meat,
uh,
whatever the last time I was on here and I made a chili out of it and then the
fucking elk burgers,
it's a little dry.
Somebody gave me a hint to put a little bit of butter in there to Kinda,
you know.
Yes.
You needed something like an egg or something to make it stick together a little
bit.
You don't want it to cook it too much cause it's super lean.
There's no fat in it.
No.
I put a piece of Swiss cheese and some per shoot on top of the fucking insane a
feel good when you eat it too.
It's a powerful food.
There's a lot of energy in those.
There's like there's,
there's so much nutrients in elk.
It's like way more protein dense,
way more nutrient dense.
That's thing kind of like the quick,
because they're wild.
I know like the human like footprint as they said,
you know acid rain and all the fucking horse should we do but at least it's,
it's,
I would like to think it's kind of a way from the Gmos and all that.
It's a type of stuff you can get.
So who knows what do to you but like the fresh shit tastes better though.
It does taste.
Does it taste better?
I mean Gmos,
everything's gene.
That's a weird word.
Like if you talk to real scientists about Gmos,
most of the time when you talk about Gmos,
we're talking to hippies and like you man,
you're got to stay away from Gmos.
Genetically Modified.
It's giving us cancer.
It's terrible for the water.
But real GMOs is almost everything we eat.
Every tomato you eat is genetically modified.
They've all been all 12 corn.
We kind of were kind of like Guinea pigs to see like what,
what's going to happen sort of.
But most of it is just splicing.
Like I just found this out recently.
You know when you buy pistachios,
there's a place up in northern California.
Was it Staci was a stash.
It goes either way.
And she's asked you who you talking to?
Sam Regal onto the thank you staff.
She has
his stash.
Yeah,
I like it with tea shelled.
Of course.
I don't Sheldon I,
so I,
I buy shelled pistachios and I feel like I'm cheating because I just take big
handfuls of them shoving my fat face.
You can't do that.
There's a reason why there's a shell on it because if you,
if you don't,
you're going to eat a thousand of them.
I buy them in these big,
uh,
like a two pound boxes and I just pour my hands and I eat them.
The good,
good for you too.
It's kind of guilt free,
but you feel like you're cheating.
Like you don't have to crack them.
I know I stared you off course.
So he was so native when they grow these pistachios,
pistachio trees,
the pistachio bushes are not a big strong tree.
So they graft the limbs of the pistachio tree onto like an avocado tree,
a thicker,
stronger tree,
and they grow pistachios on an avocado tree.
Like what the fuck?
But you'll,
how are we playing God when we're playing God but driving cars to replay on God
by flying planes.
That shit is like,
first of all,
I thought pistachios came from the ground.
I thought penis went in the ground.
Peanuts,
I think peanuts are in the ground is a pistachio.
None of the,
it wasn't George W was the,
Jimmy Carter was a peanut farmer.
How did he do it?
Should I ask him?
I think it was in the ground.
I don't know.
Fucking okay.
That's why I want to hunt.
Carrots are in the ground and just say,
oh,
worms.
They were in the ground.
Do you grow?
And he's trying to recover it that we don't know any shit.
Worms are in the ground.
Birds are in this guy dirt.
Um,
do I know?
I mean my,
my,
the guy who cuts the grass fucking put him on.
So I got tomatoes,
I got lemons and limes.
But all that did was just make me fucking like booze more.
Cause I'm just,
I get totally
got into Kipp Tequila.
It's like there's only so much guacamole you can eat.
You just like,
what the fuck else can I do with this shit?
Um,
so I kinda got into Tequila.
It's less of a hangover and do,
and I'm telling you,
you get what it was big square ice cubes.
A really nice to keep just like a patrol and silvery,
put that in there and then you go pick a fucking lime off.
I'm telling you,
it's why it's why I live out here.
It's not the show Biz.
It's the booze.
Well,
you don't really have to live out here anymore.
Right.
And especially like your podcast,
the way you do your podcast,
you just rant.
Like you could do that fucking thing and you do do it anyway.
But I also,
uh,
you know,
my wife's in the business too,
so she does acting.
She just,
he's doing a voiceover today and uh,
so she doesn't have that luxury.
And then also,
you know,
um,
she would go,
she would go crazy if,
if I,
you know,
if I just moved to like the middle of fucking now I saying and lived in the
middle of fucking nowhere,
but I do,
when I go on the road,
I always have that urge.
Like when I go to a place and I just start thinking about,
hey man,
these guys riding around motorcycles,
no helmets on,
and it's just like this,
that lake water here they got,
they got,
they got that.
It's very lush land.
Like living out here is,
is a,
it's terrifying.
It's terrifying.
Like what,
what happened to the water and silver lake?
Where did they take that?
They closed silver lake and actual lake at one point.
Yeah.
I mean it was man made,
but the water's all gone now.
They're going to develop it.
And Dad,
they said they put an underground,
they didn't really say where.
It's just,
it's just gone.
Yeah.
Do what I,
I fly.
That's like,
it's one of the things I fucker would look down and you go over at dodger
stadium and then you start coming.
Then you see silver lake and I'm looking down like where'd that parking lot with
the big top come from?
And the guy was like,
oh that was silver lake.
And they drained the water.
I don't know.
They said they put it under ground.
It's all vague there.
Do you know when I was in,
I was in Nashville this past weekend and I was sitting there watching the news
during the day and they just go like,
Oh,
and folks,
if you're in the downtown area and you see the police doing something that seems
a little disturbing.
Ah,
don't worry.
It's just an exercise.
And then they continued on and it was just like you didn't do any followup like,
or there's no more information with an exercise.
What are they practicing for that whatever they're doing is,
is like scary.
Now I'm not saying they're going to come at us.
Is it some sort of anti terrorism thing?
I have no fucking idea what it was.
But like just the,
the kind of vagueness that two hammock right before the Dodgers score the other
day,
uh,
NPR,
my wife listens to that shit and I,
you know,
and NPR morning becomes eclectic if you enjoy this show.
Fresh air with Terry Gross.
Yeah.
There's always those pauses and know when you first started doing stand,
do you know when I think of,
of discussed this before,
but it's kind of important,
you know what to think of when I think of those people.
Do you know who that Guy John Ghomeshi hands?
I like NPR,
but it's so easily to be made fun of.
It's,
it's easy to drive off the road into a fucking tree when you're listening to it,
to you.
Oh yeah.
Now there's a lot of uh,
droning on,
but that talk,
which nobody does,
that really super sensitive
leftwing style of talk.
The guys that was a,
he do that really well.
The main guy that did that was this Guy John Ghomeshi,
who was on CBC in Canada and it turned out he liked to beat the fuck out of
girls when he was having sex with them.
He would punch him in the face and club.
I'm in the head and it was crazy shit.
And one girl I aim at.
Yeah,
yeah.
Want and he would do it without asking them.
It was like,
you know,
like that's a strong move.
Pretty strong move in the rack.
Well I mean who knows what to tell you the truth because he was kind of
acquitted of a lot of it.
It was,
cause it was,
it was very difficult to find some money to get acquitted,
you know.
Well that's true.
That's a good point.
But he was fired and there was a gang of girls that came out and said he used to
pick them up.
Oh wait,
wait,
wait that the Gao does the interviews.
He talks like this bill burrs.
So tell me one time when,
I'm not saying all of,
I don't know what the fuck he does in his personal life,
but a Russell Peters was on there and he just goes like,
and he's like,
Russell,
you have nine cars.
And Russell's like,
yeah.
And he goes,
why?
And it just fucking like making him feel bad cause he's doing well.
He's,
you know,
and then Russell had to fucking basically justified and come up with money and
now I can have it.
I'm sorry I fucking made it.
Wow.
And I like cars.
Yeah.
It's so quiet.
No,
I'm not saying he's a Twat that's just saying this right there.
Well even if they're that bug me,
I hate when people fucking do stuff like that.
Had to hit somebody.
If you get like eight or nine chicks,
they're saying you beat the fuck out of my way.
You're having sex.
Even if you get off what somebody got cracked,
what is your number that innocent until guilty or how many accusations?
Bill Cosby I gave in around 30 30
I heard the first house,
but we had heard that right out around seven.
No,
I,
there was rumors of his infidelity,
but I never heard of.
You never heard that?
No,
I did.
I heard that.
I had heard that it was like a rumor.
It was a rumor that he would drug women.
It was a rumor a long time ago.
He was a,
there was a court case that is part of this case from,
I believe it was like 2005 and that was one of the reasons why they weren't
allowed to admit that evidence because the judge had made a decision that if he
paid this woman off,
then it couldn't be admissible in a future trial.
But it was all verbal.
They didn't get anything on paper.
So once they found out that it didn't get this on paper,
they're like,
well,
we're going to admit this.
And then the woman came out and then he sued the woman that he gave the money to
for drug runner.
Oh,
the whole thing is very,
very sorted.
But with Bill Cosby,
I think it's up to like 50 or something crazy.
Yeah.
So you've got to wonder,
out of those 50 there's probably like 12 that are just crazy like he dragged me
to,
but the fact,
but the fact that he'd still be open 30 it's just nuts.
You know?
It was one when all that shit came out about Trump,
right.
He did this,
he did that,
blah,
blah.
It was all pretty pedestrian sorta of like,
oh,
he grabbed my boob and then took me in the back.
Just just really generic sort
of lights become sort of the cliched story.
And then this one woman saw,
I'm sitting there going like,
guide,
the Clintons are fucking filthy.
Who knows if they paid these people?
Who knows what the fuck's going on?
It's right before the gist of when this is coming out.
And so I was going,
all right,
we'll see,
we'll see.
And then this finally,
this woman came on and she goes,
uh,
so he made advancements at me and she goes,
I just pushed him away and said,
get real.
Which is the perfect end to say,
cause you're,
you're in your 20s.
He's like fucking 106 it's like,
yeah,
you serious?
So she goes,
I said,
get real.
And then she said he trusted his genitals towards me and and said,
yeah,
get re.
Yeah,
she said that.
And the way she imitated them,
I was in the car with my wife.
I say he fucking did that.
Did that one.
There's no fucking way that he's just too specific.
Like I got the creek like you real.
So the logistics are where the legality is rather of the,
the audio tape.
Like if you don't know you're being recorded,
like you know you're being recorded for a show.
You weren't a microphone but you don't know you're being recorded while you on a
bus and you're talking about grabbing them by the pussy and all that.
Steve was talking to me.
He's talking shit.
Yeah,
like it's like Joey Diaz would say something like that and I'd be fucking
crying,
laughing and he would be egging it up.
He would ramp it up.
He would make it way exaggerated because he knows it's funny,
he's gone for the left.
If you're sitting next to Trump and he's like,
I just grab them by the Pussy.
You'd be fucking crying laughing.
That's why I really push,
I defended him on my podcast like it.
Like,
I'm not saying that guy's a great guy,
but if fire of fucking guy,
because of a fucking 22nd clip from 11 years ago,
what's he supposed to do?
He's interviewing the guy and what you're supposed to do was keep the interview
or happiness the interviewee happy.
So he's at grand by the pussy grabbing by the pussy.
Yeah.
He doesn't even say anything bad.
Billy Bush didn't say anything bad.
It just,
this guy at work said,
well when he said to the woman,
go over and give him a hug,
he became part of the sexual assault and I was just like,
what sector was no sexual assault?
What they were saying,
if he actually did it was the whole thing was just like this,
just,
you know,
I understand when we getting flipping out about it as far as obviously just the
whole,
it would be them,
but yeah,
but they don't know is the way guys talk when they're not there yet.
And I'm just,
I'm going to sit and do the fucking shit that we've said
we eat and we say it for fun.
You don't say it because we really want to go grab someone by the Pussy and pick
them up like a bowling ball and say it because it's funny.
It's funny and you just,
you're talking completely ridiculous.
And inappropriate.
Yes.
Yeah.
Say if you do have $1 billion,
I what I'm learning through Cosby and all these fucking guys is evidently you
can do that.
And he did say that he's going like,
you get famous enough,
you can just walk up and grab them by the Pussy.
And I've just said it was just so absurd to me.
I'm like,
you can do that.
You can't do that.
But he's got so much money.
You got to think when you get off that that guy could get you six grand in cash
if he,
I just don't correct.
I think he's leveraged out totally,
but I'm pretty sure he'd go to the ATM and get six grand.
But I know you're exaggerating.
Two six brands of funny number.
It's a funny number.
It is funny,
right?
I'm just saying like,
dude,
it is like liquid rich and your assets have paid off.
And then there's,
oh,
I got this,
I'm going to take a loan against this and then I'm going to do that and get some
investors here and then I'm gonna stick my fucking name on it to build my brand.
There's that way where you're sort of like steroid and up your value,
but at the end of the day it's like,
all right,
but what?
How much can you get me right fucking now?
Like I don't get that whole like,
well all my shit's tied up.
Right.
And I got other guys,
you know I'm,
I'm working with,
let me see the Zeros.
What's in your bank account?
Show me your phone.
Yes.
Sean helicopter.
The helicopter.
The name on the back.
Has that paid off?
Is that a sticker?
Is that a sticker that they take off?
And then they put fucking Mark Cuban on the back,
but name woman showing up at his house and you're having,
you're supposed to have a business lunch.
You don't know that you,
you show up.
He's got this sprawling estate that looks like a castle.
He's got these enormous grounds.
He's probably got 50 people working just at his house cause people be greeting
you.
They're taking you into these rooms.
He comes out in a $10,000 suit,
he's got diamonds and Rolexes and everything's beautiful and you're like,
Holy Shit.
Donald Trump,
his two pays like 80 grant.
What is this fucking hair?
Why doesn't he go the way you and I did you and I recognize it was over because
I don't think it was acceptable back then,
but it's,
except Jordan had to make it acceptable.
Jordan made it,
except maybe except a full black eyes.
He transcended curly Neal of the globe trotters.
It's made it acceptable for black guys.
And Brian Jordan was just,
you know,
everyone wanted to be like Mike and then I have,
when he was at the height,
those black guys young with the full head fucking hair would shave their head
just to look like those fucking insane.
They'll do that.
But what about Yule Brenner?
Yule Brenner was the first white guy to rocket and be a movie star.
Oh yeah.
The king and I.
Westworld,
the original Westworld,
not the HBO series.
You know,
I tried to buy the rights to that like fucking 10 years ago.
You did?
Yes.
World.
Yeah.
I don't know what I was going to buy.
I was just like,
this is a movie that someone's going to want to Redo because they were redoing
all these movies from my childhood.
And I was just like,
I fucking love that movie.
And the thing really loans itself because we're not at the point where you can
do any of this shit.
So it's still in the future.
You could totally,
but then,
but they wanted like a zillion dollars for,
I didn't realize it was Michael Crighton book and all that.
They wanted like millions and millions and I was just like,
all right,
I don't know.
I don't get a a like fucking 30 grand,
like a Prius.
Um,
have you watched the show?
Or this is thing.
Then the second I sat down and I watched the show,
I just watched the opening credits and I was like,
oh,
thank God,
thank God I didn't have the rights to that cause there's no fucking way I could
have pulled that off.
Like all the things like the horse running and those tendons connecting.
Um,
I've watched the first two episodes.
I'm totally in and,
uh,
I've already bugged my agent to be like,
dude,
I will fucking,
the same way when I saw breaking bad,
I just feel like I watched the first two episodes and I was like,
dude,
I will carry a tray of math in the background.
Whatever you can fucking do.
So I bugged him going like,
um,
I'm actually bullshitting that's on my agenda today.
I'm going to want to get out of this when we're done here.
And I walk home with my elk meat,
hopefully.
Um,
I've got pounds for it.
I'm going to,
uh,
I'm going to bug him about trying,
trying to get on that thing.
And uh,
there's actually,
there's a couple of actors in there that I,
I've worked with,
um,
that,
uh,
I'm just psyched that they're on,
you know,
you see,
you see friends of yours that are actually in there and they're on something
that's fucking cool tape.
My friend Tate was on last week's episode.
Yes,
world.
He's on everything though.
Tate's Tate's been in,
I dunno,
a hundred movies,
probably easily a hundred movies have always wondered if you know,
when you're,
you're doing something great cause it's so hard when you're shooting it and how
they just,
all right now his point of view would do the master of backpack back and do all
that type of stuff you need.
You just find yourself walking around it.
Was it good?
Did it,
it was a camera crew's not saying anything.
Everybody's fucking quiet.
And it's uh,
it really comes down though to,
to the editors in the music and all that.
They can either take it to the next level or they can relate and make something
good look great and they can take something great look fucking horrific.
Well,
something started off great and then they don't know how to end it and they fuck
it up.
But there's something weird about having a friend in a movie where you go and
this movie is Great.
Oh there's Tate like takes you out of it.
It's like,
oh that's my friend.
Like this movie's bullshit.
Yeah.
People always say it doesn't,
it doesn't,
it doesn't take me,
it doesn't take me out of it unless I see them like watching themselves.
Like I can't believe I'm in this scene with this guy.
Then then it like pulls me out.
But like I,
I,
I buy in when I'm one of those guys,
like I don't like going to horror movies.
Like they freak me out.
I buy in,
I don't give a fuck what the concept is.
Like that fucking thing where the lady was like flipping the light switch off
and then turn it on and on and then flipped it off and saw the thing again and
then turn it on and then flipped off.
It was right there.
I was literally at home.
I stopped fucking turning.
Well,
movies that,
I dunno,
like the movie was coming out and it was like the thing where she's like,
she's like,
you know when you look into a room and you shut the lights off,
shuts the lights off and all of a sudden it's this fucking thing there.
Sort of a girl sort of fucking Beasley and it's across the room.
So you can't quite see it.
It's just like,
what the fuck is that?
Turns the lights on.
It's gone.
Shuts it off.
It's there again.
Same spot.
Turns the lights back on.
It's not there.
Shuts it off the third time and it's right in her fucking grill.
Yeah.
Scared the fuck out of me.
Blair witch,
Blair witch.
When they would go through to move,
you didn't skim and Ralphie may go,
no,
they didn't fucking scared the shit out of me.
I saw that movie by myself.
I'd done a spot at the laugh factory and went down to the Mann's Chinese theater
though,
the one that got Hollywood galaxy.
I don't know if that's still there anymore.
Right next door.
And I saw like the midnight showing by myself.
Dude freaked those dinner.
Yeah,
but nobody I knew when it was like really sort of like,
there wasn't a lot of people there and then that walked through the parking
garage.
Oh Dude,
I was fucking,
I was freaked.
I saw that movie in Houston,
Texas.
Chris Mcguire and I did a show.
We did a show at the old laugh stop.
You ever do the old laptop and river
oaks?
Did I do that one dre club?
I think I just,
whatever the classic one was that Hixon all those guys,
it had just moved to the new spot to spot sucked.
The new spa was not good,
but the old spot was amazing and that's where I did my first album.
That was a,
I'm going to be dead Sunday.
I did in 1999 we did a show and then McGuire and I met these kids that worked
across the street at the movie theater and they go,
Hey,
do you guys,
we have the keys to the movie theater.
Do you guys want to go watch the Blair witch?
Just us.
And we were like,
Holy Shit,
let's do it.
So we left.
We had a 10 o'clock show.
It's like midnight.
We go across the street,
they fucking cook up the popcorn and the whole deal gave us free Sosa lock the
door.
You could even do that today.
It was amazing.
I mean today everything's digital,
you know,
the kid spools up the fucking,
the real and everything like that.
And we sat down in the theater,
it was like three of them and two of us,
and we watched the Blair witch and shit,
our pants.
It was awesome.
Oh my God,
Josh screaming.
I still remember that when the kid staring in the corner.
Oh yeah.
When they just sorta like went past it again.
All of that shit where it rather than just showing you saw on somebody's head
off.
Just the idea when you think of like Tarantino talked about that where in
reservoir dogs,
he had one scene where they showed the guy hacking the year off versus just
panning away and hearing the guy screaming.
It's just like,
it was way more fucking disturbing that,
that ruined that song for me for a long time.
I always hear what song was that Marvin Nash screaming.
Um,
uh,
now here Stephen writes voice,
Lynn,
I don't know if,
oh yeah man.
And he's in
that was that said something to
remember that when he,
he through adding a fun song to a horrific scene,
that was so the powerlessness of just fucking,
I can't,
I can't deal with,
that's like Scarface member Scarface.
When they cut the guy up with a chainsaw,
he's tied up in the,
in the bathtub
and they forced Tony Montana to watch.
He's getting splattered with blood as a hack his friend up.
Yeah.
No
mother
took us to see that.
She didn't know what it was.
Took all of us to see.
And my youngest brother was like nine I think.
And if my,
if my mother said after this chainsaw scene we have to get out of here,
I would have been like,
fine.
Cause I'm been watching that going,
oh that goes really?
I asked my mother years later,
she was just like,
well yeah.
I thought at that point,
yes,
that it might've been a little mature,
mature for your youngest brother and,
but I was laughing.
I was going,
yeah,
but you always took us to cool movie.
She goes and she goes,
yeah,
she goes,
that was a good move.
She goes,
I'm gonna take care of those stupid things like she was against like the whole,
uh,
she took us to for love of Benji and Herbie goes to Monte Carlo and then they,
my parents were just like,
we're not fucking sitting through this shit.
We're going to go to a movie that we're going to enjoy too.
And then I went from that to like stripes and like scarf do.
Your parents isn't fuck kid wears it.
Said fuck it.
We're going to go,
but we're going to go out.
We're going to go.
Yeah,
we're going to see something,
but let's leave me.
I'm sweating like a pig.
Can you turn the AC on here?
Let's uh,
let's get to,
um,
let's get to what I wanted to promote here.
Uh,
you got your standup special triggered coming out.
So first of all,
all right,
when is it,
when is it airing?
I'm not what I'm saying it,
I'm going to say,
where did you shoot it?
This is what,
I'm bad as an interviewer.
I'm bad to us.
I'm trying to think of what I'm supposed to ask you about.
What did you shoot?
San Francisco.
The Fillmore.
Oh you did?
Yeah,
I want to do it at a comedy club.
And uh,
there was like a debate between Netflix and me.
Netflix wanted to do it at a huge place.
I wanted to do it at a tiny place cause I did my last one at the comedy works in
Denver,
which is only like a couple hundred people.
And I liked that.
I think there's something about when you're sitting in a living room and you're
sitting on the couch,
you're watching a comedy special,
it lends itself better to be in,
in a,
like a club.
When you're filming it,
it feels more intimate.
You know what I see,
like you're on top of the crowd.
It's leads more like what it would be like the environment that it would be.
So,
uh,
we made a compromise.
We did the film or theater,
which is a fucking really cool theater and it's only 450 seats.
It's pretty small.
It's got a high ceiling and it's kind of a big stage and everything like that.
But it's a fairly small place,
but it's cool.
But next one I'm going to do in a small place,
I think I think I might do at the store.
He was funny is when I went to go do mine at the Tabernacle.
You had already been there and did one.
So I was like,
how am I going to make this different?
And I did the Fillmore in 2009 let it go.
I did that.
Yeah.
So I think we're,
we're going back and forth.
You do.
And your new one,
uh,
I did it last Friday.
You did it?
Yep.
I did it at the Ryman in Nashville.
Dude.
I just,
I was just there.
I fucking loved that place.
Place is crazy.
He used to do the Grand Ole Opry,
Cedric the entertainer,
just a did one there.
So I uh,
watched like the opening to his just to see,
cause I was just like,
cause then you got to kind of disguise it so it doesn't look like,
oh my God,
he's at the exact same fucking place,
you know,
you know it guys huge.
So I had to make sure I will.
It's like all right,
well we got to try to,
you know,
he came in with like a whole marching band and all of that,
which is the exact opposite to my style.
So I was like,
okay cool.
Kat Williams brought a lion.
He brought out a lion on stage.
That's awesome.
I love that guy.
That guy's fucking hilarious man.
He's fucking hilarious.
Funniest guys alive.
And you know,
and just having the balls to go on stage with a fucking line is hilarious.
How did you come?
I want to,
I wish I was in that fucking pitch meeting.
Like all right,
here's the thing,
what's the concept?
I'm coming on stage with a lion.
The lion in a cage,
like a stuffed,
banal,
real one.
He's,
he got so sweaty during this special,
he had to stop and change clothes.
Is that right?
Yeah.
He literally stopped cause I'll be right back and went back stage changes.
Fucking cool.
He was drenched.
I mean just completely soaked with sweat is if they pull,
when they put that HD makeup on and then there's all those lights on you.
Yeah.
And then then you're going hard cause it's just special and you really want to
make sure you're going to get a good one.
And then if the fucking AC is a little messed up,
if the,
if the crowd's all fucking packed in,
in the wrong venue,
yeah,
you can get yourself into a situation.
I don't wear makeup on those things.
I wouldn't wear it for comedy central and a word for the UFC.
I don't wear for anything.
I just like,
I don't know if this is what I looked like,
you know,
I think it came first of all from fear factor.
Uh,
when I first started doing fear factor,
they wanted it,
they would put like a little anti shine on me.
A little of this,
a little that and after a while I'm like,
look,
these fucking people are covered in blood.
I mean,
they've got dirt all over their face and I'm sitting there with makeup on.
You have to touch me up in between scenes.
You know how ridiculous that is.
Yes.
And then we would go from that to the UFC where people were literally,
their faces are getting busted open there.
Get giant fucking,
it's funny,
I never noticed like when I watched you on the UFC,
I never noticed like,
oh wow.
Like he can,
he went on TV without makeup.
That's so brave.
That's such a courageous thing.
I you just,
you look like you.
Well that's what I look like,
you know?
I'm just like,
I'm not,
you know,
my Golberg gets it.
They spray it on.
They got a fucking airbrush.
I'm not kidding.
They have an airbrush.
They do it to everybody.
All the ring girls and everything.
The airbrush them.
That's what they didn't go that fight.
I do my giant forehead.
I got to get some and forehead out.
Dude,
I got you beat through to you
guys.
You're not in the same way classes when,
when a crazy on stage.
I sweat like crazy.
I mean my,
my last special,
I looked at it when I was doing the editing.
I'm like,
Jesus,
I'm a sweaty fuck.
Like it just looks ridiculous.
It looks like I'm like,
I'm on drugs,
but you're up there working and you're not like just standing there.
So this one I didn't have any,
uh,
this last one I made sure the AC was cranked.
Like with each special I learned something.
Yeah.
Uh,
so I was like,
make sure the eight,
you know,
the AC cranked don't fucking cake the makeup on or whatever,
just so it was just a little bit of that.
That's,
that's,
that's all of those stupid little fucking things,
you know,
don't stick my parents in the front row.
Please thank them.
It's just beyond,
beyond,
beyond the Pale.
And I don't show any audience anymore.
I decided no more audience.
She never did.
Yeah.
That's their way to go.
No audience shots and everything.
Kinda mostly from the waist up.
Unless you need to see my legs for like a particular thing I'm doing.
I want to know all your secrets because,
because now I feel like,
um,
because there's so many specials coming out,
so many fucking special's coming out that uh,
you know,
that then it becomes like you,
you have to have like whatever you'll look is,
you know what I mean?
I mean,
the thing about it is you have such a great act that's going to stand on
anyways,
but if you can add like your own sort of style,
the way you shoot them,
that becomes part of your thing.
That's another way to try to get it out.
Cause you know,
you're going to Netflix with the special dude.
You just,
you're fucking scrolling,
scrolling,
scrolling.
I guess.
So I just wanted it to be like,
you're watching it like no cutaways.
I don't want to cut into the left into the right cut and for no reason.
Like,
like I,
there was a director that I worked with wants,
who was like,
you know,
we'd have to cut to the audience,
that's how we're going to do our edits.
I go,
let's just try and deal with no edits.
We can,
we can't.
I go,
of course we can.
If I do a good show,
we could do it with no edits.
He was like,
no,
look,
trust me,
we're going to do this.
I'm like,
no,
this is my fucking special.
Like I don't even know you.
Yeah.
Like you're,
you're coming in here and you wanted to do all this stupid shit and film the
crowd and you know that people want to know the people are laughing.
I'm like,
they're going to hear them laugh and I can take it.
In my opinion,
it takes you out of it because one cell phone.
Yeah,
perfect.
He sits down for like an hour and 40 minutes chilling.
They never,
they never go to the crowd.
The background just slowly changes different colors and guy absolutely murdered.
You and I were supposed to go see bill Cosby and Vegas.
We had made like a,
we were talking about doing it,
but we both flaked and we never wound up doing it and that's one of my main
regrets to this day.
I would have liked to see him before the stink hit him.
I did.
I saw it right before I met him and then three months later I saw him.
Do you remember when he was doing shows still like all those women were coming
out and he was still doing shows,
like he was still doing shows.
He was like,
fuck it,
I'm still doing them.
And he went out and he still did those shows for a little while.
I think he thought he was powerful enough to just sort of ignore it.
And then it wasn't going to La.
It wasn't going to come around.
But dude,
I gotta tell you if you gave me a thousand guests,
not a thousand,
but if you gave me 200 guests as his name would not be on that out of all the
fun of all the fucking people.
Like if you,
if you said,
okay,
this is a comic out there doing this shit,
really,
you got your top 20 where you'd be like,
Oh yeah.
You know,
why didn't I never heard the rumors?
I did hear the rumors and also there was a time I might not in the club house.
How am,
how am I a comedian this long and I'm not fucking here in the rumors.
I heard it from Hollywood people.
I didn't hear it from comics.
I heard it from people in the business.
I heard it from like actors and from people that like work on TV shows,
sets.
I heard it during the news radio days.
I had heard it.
Yeah,
he was doing it at the show.
He was doing it to people that were on the ship or two,
two people allegedly who the fuck knows,
but there's something.
It was something unbelievable.
Unbelievably creepy.
But after the accusations came out,
when he was still doing shows,
he would go on stage with one.
I look into the left one.
I look at strict.
He developed a dead I somewhere along the line.
Right.
So He'd go on stage with that.
Weird,
I have some slack.
He's like nine.
I Know David for the grace of God,
but he's dying,
right?
I mean that's my point.
It's like things are falling off the wheels,
right.
The wheels are falling off the ride and he's got the shirt on this sweater on
that says hello friend and he's,
he's on stage and he walks out there and everybody's clapping and cheering and
some guys,
Yana,
you're a rapist,
you are a rapist.
And then they grabbed the guy and shuffle them out and then people going,
we love you bill.
And he just doesn't even acknowledge that.
Just ignore them.
Yeah.
It was something crazy about that.
It was like the last,
the last sparks before they throw the water on the fire.
It's like there was just a little hope like,
yes,
some embers blast spark before they to the gas.
You mean?
I mean his career,
his life,
they threw water on him.
Like,
I mean he's just,
it's over.
Like no one's going to go see him life now.
Right.
I mean it's kind of over.
It doesn't water put out the sparks.
Yes.
That's what I mean.
The through the water on them,
they said it.
Wouldn't that mean that he saved it?
He had,
no,
I mean like you had a moment of like there was still some sparks and oh okay,
I kicked the accusations came out,
but he was still doing these shows and people still came out and they're like,
we love you bill.
He's got these shirts,
analogies to me,
I'm not the brightest.
It wasn't a good analogy.
You're right.
Analogies probably better.
You know the,
the,
the blowing the,
the flames on the fire.
It's like we almost had it out.
Like it was almost,
you know,
my last flight sort of caught on fire wise.
Helicopter flight.
No,
no,
no.
We were playing
air jet flying back from my special Nashville,
the La and we got up to cruising altitude.
It smelled like burnt popcorn.
So I was like,
did the stewardesses is like,
I'll fast forward through this.
Cause I told her,
he told him,
I think I was like,
did they burn the fucking meal or something?
And then it sort of went away.
Then it kind of came back and I felt this with everybody had the shades pulled
down and I felt like we were starting to descend.
And then it felt really like,
I felt like the wing shaken and shit and I was like,
oh wow man,
like there must be some turbulence.
I thought he was just descending to go underneath it and then go back up again.
You know,
they didn't get a little bit of a smoother air here.
Sorry about the mummy ride.
If I was going to be doing that,
she had never said a fucking word.
And then all of a sudden like Mike drink that was in the lead,
little middle armrests started sliding forward like it was going to fall into
the floor.
And I'm like,
Oh fuck.
And then the stewardess came up.
She goes,
yeah,
we're going to be landing here shortly.
So I have to take those drinks.
Right.
And then the woman next to me so landed premature.
Oh yeah.
We only 50 minutes into the flight from Nashville to La.
My favorite thing was the woman next to me take the headphones off.
She's like,
are we here ready that way?
Just fucking tell we were on the Concorde.
I was like,
no,
I was on fire.
I Dunno.
I Dunno what it was.
I always thinking like,
oh fuck,
this is going to be something in somebody's bag.
Like the luggage is shit or some shit.
Like that value jet,
something caught on fire underneath there.
And like my whole thing was when we were going down,
I wasn't nervous because he had full control of the plane,
maneuvering it and all that.
And I just knew like,
yeah,
if you,
if you smell smoke that is a,
uh,
the procedure is land immediately.
So that's what he's doing and we're at 30,000 feet up so he's going to land
quickly.
That's the shaking.
That's fine.
I feel as making turns and banks,
everything's working.
But my whole thing is,
you know,
I don't know anything about planes,
but I'm just like,
if it burns through the wrong wire,
if the hydraulics,
like what the fuck's going to happen?
So,
um,
yeah.
And we came into a landing and little rock and we came in like over this river
and I couldn't see the runway.
Oh cause you can't see straight.
So I'm just going at to sign.
I just see this fucking river going to be following it.
That's something that like,
is he going to sell this thing and fucking sentence into the water?
And I was already thinking,
and you know what's going to happen?
The front part of the plane's going to get fucked up so that door's not gonna
open some fucking fight.
Pass these FirstClass people into coach.
You know what I mean?
We're real people work.
So they're going to be out.
They're going to out muscle me as they get through this.
I'm going to be fucked if we use the first class though,
I can take out the check next to me.
I'm fine.
People are going to be unconscious anyway,
just from the stress and the impact.
Do you know it's uh,
was hilarious.
Was the,
the woman across the alphabet,
it was totally freaking out because unfortunately her dad I guess had died in a
plane crash.
So she was totally like,
like totally fucking hyperventilating to the point it was making me angry.
Like how fucking freaked out she was.
Well,
what kills me is she's tall.
She's totally freaking out about that,
but I swear to God,
Dude,
like 10 minutes earlier,
barefoot walked in,
use the bathroom and came back out.
That doesn't scare her.
But a fucking a couple of lights on in the cockpit,
you know,
and the smell of burnt popcorn.
Now she's freaking out barefoot.
What the Fuck I put in the bathroom is,
is a new thing.
I've been flying for 20 years.
I've never seen it.
It started it with socks and now it's fun socks or even fucking worse.
He's like,
you obsess store pissed.
But whatever happened to women where they decided to wear shoes that hurt like w
if they always have.
But what the fuck is that about?
That is we chose the of the,
of their lack of power,
uh,
they couldn't get a good job.
You know what I mean?
Believe me,
if it was switched the other way,
if you made a dollar less an hour,
I,
you could imagine the shoe should be wearing right now.
Joe,
do you know that that's not true?
Do you know that at that whole thing about the the,
the gender disparity,
the wage gap is not true.
Do you know what the variable that actually is?
It's choices in jobs.
It's not job for job.
Like if you were an engineer and you work next to a woman,
she wouldn't be making 70 cents to your dollar.
It's bullshit.
It's a lie and it's one of those propaganda things that they like to tout out.
And you heard fucking Obama talk about it.
Sarah Silverman talked about and when she was trying to get Hillary Clinton
elected,
it's a,
it's a weird thing that people keep.
I thought she was with Bernie Sanders.
I thought Sarah Sylvan was with Hillary Clinton.
I thought it was initially Bernie Sanders.
Maybe she was then everybody jumped ship and went fucking Hillary include Bernie
who then fucking endorsed Hillary and so it's like that.
Why would you do?
That'd be because your credibility.
You're
right.
It might be Bernie.
She was endorsing,
but it's that thing that they say that's just not true.
What it is.
It's two.
It's two factors.
One,
there's the law.
This,
the less hours.
Women tend to work less hours.
They also tend to take risks because they're lazy.
Well,
it just have the kids choking maternity leave,
one for the left.
There's maternity leaves is a bunch of other factors.
There are less crazy,
less ambitious.
They don't have as much testosterone.
Obviously.
They're not just,
it's fucking crazy man or be willing to work themselves into the grave and when
they're working side by side doing the same job,
there's almost no disparity at all.
There's a few jobs where men get paid more than women,
but it's not much and it's certainly not 70 cents to the dollar,
and this is one thing that gets touted out over and over again by people,
but it's just not true.
I have no idea.
I'll look.
I had a friend of mine who I got in an argument about it when he's talking about
divorce,
where we were talking about a buddy of ours that got fucked in a divorce and he
goes,
hey,
maybe it's to make up for the fact that women only make 70 cents now.
I go,
okay.
The fact that you say that drives me fucking crazy because you think it's a good
point.
Don't yet.
And he goes,
yeah,
I do you ever research that?
And he goes,
no,
but it's a fact.
I go,
it's not a fact.
They make 70 cents compared to guys.
Yes,
the guy said this.
He's a guy who likes to argue.
He's a friend of mine,
likes to argue.
He's one of those guys.
You just got it.
Yeah,
you got to walk away from it.
Now he's a good guy.
He's a good guy,
but he's got a fucking problem.
He doesn't like when he doesn't know something and when he doesn't know
something he go,
he doesn't go,
Holy Shit.
Really?
He goes,
that's not true.
And I go,
what the fuck?
It's true.
It's fucking true.
Like go Google it.
Like we got an a big fucking crazy web series.
I want to watch you guys drive from here to San Francisco.
Just watching you losing your shit.
It's fucking true.
Couple of times we've gotten in these arguments,
we've gotten like three of them and he's like,
I,
when I'm not,
when I don't know something,
I'll say,
I don't know.
Or if someone says something and I didn't know that,
I'll go,
holy shit.
Is that true?
He's the opposite.
He's like,
that's not true.
So,
Oh,
if I don't know something,
I'll do a bit on it twice.
Twice.
This fucking guy's done this beside that.
Like I know what I'm talking about,
but I might get a bit on the wage gap on my new,
my new special.
Yeah.
Well there you go.
Won't fit on.
My whole thing was like,
how the fuck did they find out what everybody makes you just call up the IRS.
Can we get that to on everybody?
They're going to give you that information.
Well,
uh,
I dunno.
I Dunno.
I have no idea,
but all I know is this what?
It's harder for them straight across the board.
That is the three women,
just everything is harder and all of our lives are easier.
That's the overall fucking message.
You see you're being sarcastic.
I am.
I have one of my favorite jokes of all time.
What about motherhood being the hardest job in the world?
He goes,
how's the hardest job in the world when you were a fucking pajamas all day?
Yeah.
No job you can do when you pajamas.
I love that bit.
My wife hates it.
No,
no,
I'm not saying it's,
it's not fucking no,
but it's fine.
It's fine.
Obviously difficult,
but it's a funny post still go work on an oil rig.
That fucking blows up.
Exactly and as you jump into the fucking like on fire water going underneath
that and then he's just sitting there with second degree burns and salt fucking
water hoping that coast guard gets there before the Sharkey t alive.
I talked to me about your,
talk to me about the terrible twos.
I have a friend of mine who works at a oil rig in Canada in northern Alberta
work it's 50 below zero and I go,
well why do you do it?
Cause they work outside.
I go,
how'd he do it?
He goes,
well you keep the truck running and you work for about seven to 10 minutes at a
time and then you have to go inside the truck for about a half an hour.
I go,
really?
He goes,
yeah.
you can't take it anymore cause you any exposed skin you have,
you try to cover your face up as much as possible.
You put a ski mask on,
but just your eyes just all around your eyes is all fucked up like everything's
fucked up.
It's like it's just too cold.
You just can't do it.
50 below zero.
They just work for short stretches of time.
Then they'd go in the car and then the other guy will go out while he's in there
and then he'll go out for like 10 minutes and then they take a break for another
10 15 minutes.
Then the first guy,
we'll go back out again.
All of those shows make me so thankful that I'm a comedian.
Those fucking fishing shows
the fucking worst job.
You had this as far as physically like I will kill myself,
perform 30 if I fucking do this.
Out of high school,
I worked on a,
uh,
there was a knights of Columbus Hall that was having a wheelchair ramp built and
I had a carry cement bags and pressure treated lumber every day and I only
lasted a little over two weeks.
I think I lasted eight days.
I was a gopher on a construction site.
We will,
we will roofing in June or July.
And I just remember having to bring up those,
first of I brought the Ra,
I bought the wrong color,
fucking shingles.
They wanted the fucking ebony one and this was off Alabama.
What the fuck it was.
So I had to go all the way back,
unload the fucking things.
I loaded on load some more back,
brought the fucking things back.
I just remember,
dude,
it was just like,
I never ate so much in my life.
Like I'd eat like three sandwiches and like a half hour later I'd be like
starving and weight was just falling off of me.
I was just like,
dude,
what the fuck?
This is insane.
And,
but the thing was if I hung in there for like a month,
I would have gotten my sea legs.
But I,
I just was like,
no.
But I,
I didn't have it.
I knew it.
I always knew.
I always knew like when I play drums and everything like that as much,
every time I thought I was getting good,
I go into guitar center and some eight year old kid would get on a kid and I'd
be like,
holy fuck.
Like I W I was like,
dude,
I would pay you to give me lessons.
And it's just like,
then when you switched,
when whatever you're trying to do,
when you see like a kid come in and he fucking blow,
I mean blows you away.
It's just like,
it's just like,
oh,
I,
this is,
this is a hobby bill.
This is a hobby.
Well,
he's not a working,
doing construction.
It's definitely not a fucking hobby.
It's just brutal labor.
There's ink is,
it's,
it is a gift as far as like seeing how things go together.
Oh yeah.
Dude,
this is an art to everything.
It's a construct Louie showcase of fucking contractors.
Oh No.
I mean as far as building houses,
but I mean laboring like carrying bags of cement.
There's no fucking art.
The carrying bags of cement.
But no,
but they would give me shit to do like,
you know,
make this fucking miter cut 45 and I fucked the same cut up three times in a
row.
It was up to frame a door jam and I kept measuring to the inside of the corner,
rather the outside of the corner.
Remember the third time I did it that my boss just looked at me,
grabbed the wood and he looked at me the whole time,
walked up to the frame and never,
never took his eyes off me and the frame is behind them and you just stuck it to
the fucking wall and just stared at me.
I was so embarrassed.
So it's just like,
oh God dude.
He's like,
dude,
you're going through,
you went through like fucking $20 what?
The stock to make one one fucking cut.
Like what are you doing here?
I was just like,
just,
I didn't even pick on,
I can show.
I didn't even pick up my check.
I drove up to the site,
I work Monday through Friday and then Monday,
Tuesday,
Wednesday,
I drove up to the site and I just looked at it and my body,
everything just said,
dude,
fuck this.
And I just kept driving.
He never called,
why would he call me?
I'm the guy waste in lumber.
He doesn't give a shit.
He got free labor out of me and I didn't give a fuck.
And um,
I forget what I did after that.
But that was a rough time for me.
But like,
I always knew like if I,
if I didn't like a job and stuff like that.
So it's like the Deniro thing and what was that?
The heat you gotta be willing to walk in any moment.
You gotta be willing to fucking walk.
You got to know it's bad.
Yeah.
That was it.
That was the probably the toughest physical job that I had.
And it was also a good,
it was a good lesson because it was a lesson that like if you worked for
somebody else and you're just doing labor,
he just doing just mindless labor.
You don't have any time for anything else.
You think you got eight hours in a day and there's still another 16 you'll get
shit done.
You're exhausted,
you fucking beat and I would go to the gym.
I try to work out and I remember trying to hit the bag and I just had nothing.
There was nothing that I'd never felt so tired in my life and it was only like
18 I should have been full of piss and vinegar.
I was just dead.
And I remember like all my ambition wheels would just ramp it up.
I was like,
okay,
this is not my fucking future.
I got to figure out what the fuck I'm doing cause I,
I had these delusions that I was going to become a carpenter.
I was like,
wow,
getting the union,
I'll start building houses.
That's a good gig.
Which it is.
You know,
if you're,
that's what I thought I was going to do.
Yeah.
You know what,
it's a good gig if you're the guy telling the people to go build a fucking
house.
But if you're the guy out there pouring the forms,
even noticed that that's mostly young guys like that is a fucking young.
Even like landscaping,
like after awhile you got to get a crew and you got to be the guy like sending
the crews out.
Cause there's only so long that you can just even like,
I feel like like laborers and that they have like the same career trajectory as
like a professional athlete.
Somewhere around 35 to 38,
your body is going to be like,
dude,
I can't,
I can't fucking do this anymore.
You just break down.
There was a,
I had a bulging disc in my neck and I went to a,
an MRI place and uh,
there was a lady who went in before me,
this lady and this lady,
uh,
I was looking at different people's Mris and this lady had the most fucking
ridiculous cartoon bulge of her disc.
Some poor woman who,
uh,
I think she worked in a laundry mat or something like that,
just carrying baskets of clothes and her back was just so fucked up and she was
probably like 40 years old or something like that.
Came over your hair from Mexico or Guatemala or something.
And I remember looking at her back like in like,
this poor lady has no choice.
She has to go to work.
There's no way around this.
And there's no jobs for her other than this,
you know,
like what?
She's,
she can't speak English like she's got to do what the fuck she's got to do.
And she had you went into our chart,
Huh?
He started reading right there.
It was just sitting up there on the screen right now.
And I asked the guy,
whose bag is that?
He goes,
it's her.
It's like a holy Shit I got is mine looked that?
He goes,
no.
that's bad.
He goes out.
It's bad.
It's real bad.
Like she could barely walk.
Look,
she had sciatica up and down her leg.
Oh,
I had that.
Yeah.
Well that's what that is.
Like,
what Sciatica is the bulging disc to disc that's pressing against the nerves you
had it would you do about it?
I went to,
I'm a sous that helped.
Oh yeah.
And she actually,
she works on a,
she's a magician dude.
She started with like,
uh,
I came real who she
started with,
but what,
how it came through me was through my drum teacher.
So it was like MMA people.
Ah,
okay.
And then,
uh,
you know,
the whole sum drummer,
a guitarist or something was into MMA,
fucked up something and he say go to Moma Seuss.
And then she got all the musicians with like that,
what are the tendinitis and all that shit in the forearms.
And then,
uh,
it came around to me through my drum teacher and uh,
she,
she was like,
I made it like my left side was fucked up,
like the left leg.
And she started with my right shoulder.
Cause you're,
Rachel is compensating for your left side.
Yeah.
So she was doing the whole,
I,
let's try to get some information,
you know,
see what's going on here.
And then she'd do something.
I just go like,
it should be like,
she just be like,
she'd be like,
okay,
this some inflammation.
All right.
And then scale of one to 10,
the pain and dude like,
um,
she,
what she did for me,
like literally she went so fucking deep.
It was like these memories come out.
I'm in.
My brother used to just give me charley horses and shit for no fucking reason.
I remembered it.
Yeah.
Like I think it was a store,
like the pain of it,
it just pops up.
I just,
I wouldn't be like literally thinking and you just have the thought that hey,
my brother used to always kicked me in the fucking leg there.
And there was another one.
I remember I was playing pickup hockey and I had no stuff.
All I had was the fucking,
uh,
the,
the helmet and the gloves and the skate had like sweatpants and like a fucking
tee shirt or whatever.
And I'm out there like an asshole and I've,
you know,
going down the ice and all of a sudden the other team gets it.
So I pop over to fucking start skating backwards.
I caught an edge and just went up in the air and just landed on my left ass
cheek and fucking that whole side dude,
I landed so fucking hard.
Like I couldn't breathe and my eyes were watering.
It's like literally been when you're skating it's like being thrown out of a
moving car.
Right.
So I got up and everyone was laughing.
I fucked up my elbow,
you know,
it's hockey,
see just fine.
You know,
I get to the bench and I was fine and,
and a couple of shifts later,
it kind of worked itself out and I had bruised my leg so bad.
It was like three days later I was on the road and I was showering or something.
I just saw on the side of my leg,
it looked like I had sat in Greece or something and I then I looked all the way
to the back of my leg.
It looked like someone took a pipe and just had fucking whacked me.
As hard as you could have crossed the back of my leg,
it,
let's get this straight fucking line.
And I think my sciatic nerve thing was,
which is a combination of all of that shit.
And then there was that last thing that did it.
So she fucking worked all the way out of that.
She gave me all these stretches and then I found like a good chiropractor and
all that.
And um,
I had been so good now.
Yeah,
I'll do it.
I couldn't,
I couldn't even sit down because of,
uh,
my,
my feet were stuck,
would start to tingle and stuff with numbness is way worse than pit.
That's beyond pain is what I heard.
Still the numbness thing is worse.
So she goes,
all right,
we're going to work you from numbness down to pain and then pain,
hopefully down to that.
And not just,
I just started going every fucking week,
but uh,
I've got a machine I have to show you.
It's a reverse hyper and it's a machine that decompresses your back while
strengthening it.
It's your,
your lift weights with it.
You lift your legs up and then it strengthens your back.
And then as you lift your legs,
galleys Shit.
Well,
I work for the ultimate fighting championship.
I mean,
I've been an athlete my whole life shit for every time I get this fucking
chamber,
I pay attention to stuff.
I mean,
that's what I do.
I,
I mean,
I've been tension to the wrong shit.
I've been doing martial arts since I was a little kid.
I mean it maintaining your body's a big part of that.
It's one of the most difficult parts of martial arts is not getting injured all
the time.
Your con,
because martial arts are all about hurting people,
right?
So it's practicing,
hurting each other.
So like you have to find good partners and then you'll always,
that guy in class then goes to fucking hot.
There's always that.
That's Charlie Murphy talking about that guy.
Yeah.
Was a big problem.
Kelly sent me and I only lasted a couple of weeks in the Dojo and my fucking
add,
maybe I'll learn how to cook now.
You know,
I just,
I left her,
but she,
I was just like,
is the deal you're going to go down there?
When was this?
Oh,
back we doing the rich bitch tour.
Really?
Yeah.
You were doing.
We could have martial arts reading,
whatever style he has.
His fucking black dude.
I only,
I only lasted like two weeks.
I fucking,
I actually took Jujitsu with dom fig.
Did you really?
In the late nineties I lasted like five weeks of doing that actually.
Did I write?
I did.
All right.
But then the guy teaching,
he couldn't speak English and this lady like dislocated like her fucking rib
cage can,
something fucked up happened and he didn't know what to do and I just remembered
like,
you know,
it was coming home with bruises and shit.
It was like,
that was like when pilot season you could actually get on something and I was
just like,
the fuck am I doing?
Why don't I make enough money where I have security get to actually get on
something funny.
You remember development deals?
Yeah.
And Shit could actually happen.
And you go to Montreal and get a deal and then you'd be set.
I just remember the guy who go skip the hip.
It's like this no good.
It's like this Ah,
is good.
That was the whole fucking class.
Portuguese like these?
No,
like this escape,
escape shrimp,
skip the hip,
whatever the fuck he was saying.
And um,
you know,
I,
I learned some shit.
I still know if I'm on my back,
had to get somebody into an arm bar,
but it's probably,
well it was probably,
I look at martial arts,
it's like comedy.
So like I think that that worked in the late nineties but now that would be,
it'd be like a Corny joke now.
And I just think like that movie be like,
Dude,
you're gonna fucking try that.
Like an eight year old knows how to get out of that.
Like you're funny at the office,
you think you're going to go kill it.
The Ryman auditorium.
Yeah.
Right.
That's the difference.
Yeah.
It's more like a time thing.
We're like,
that was probably state of the art shit,
whatever.
We stayed in the yard then.
I mean,
you're talking to it.
Oh my God.
I was like 18 years ago.
There's no fucking way that move.
Everybody knows that moves.
It's like playing drums.
Well,
actually all the standard old school moves.
A Brazilian Jiu Jitsu are still good.
They're all still good.
If you're good,
I'm like,
there's some guys that are really good at what you would call basic is a weird
classics.
Yeah,
basics.
A weird word and people get upset when you say they're Jujitsu is very basic,
but some of the best guys ever have what you call basic Jujitsu.
It's not that it's basic,
it's just they have only a amount
of moves that they use,
but they have them sharp into a razor's edge and it's not that they not,
they're not capable of doing everything else.
It just,
some guys like there's guys that are known for just having a guillotine choke.
That's all they do and you can just got to avoid that fucking guillotine choke
and they might still get you with it.
There's some guys that just went by triangle
all the time,
only by triangle and there's guys who only wind by,
he'll hook.
There's a bunch of different guys.
Shit.
Who's like the California kid?
Uriah Faber.
Oh Dude,
that guy's hilarious.
Did you see him when,
when he was on the ultimate fighter?
Sure.
Okay.
That thing that he,
when he gave that kid shit early on when he was trying to make the show and
whatever,
he got caught and pick a move,
whatever the fuck it,
rear naked choke or something like that.
And then when the kid went,
the kid goes in and he loses rear naked choke.
And as he went out like a Uriah just goes like,
yeah,
he goes,
that's what he's known for.
Look them up.
And what I loved about that,
it was like old school parenting,
like no fucking sympathy.
It's just like,
and it,
and I thought it was a very empowering thing to do to that person.
Like if he,
once he got past the defeat,
like you'd be sitting there going like,
yeah,
what the fuck?
You know,
that this is what the guy did.
Let him beat you with anything else.
But that,
that's so easy and this is on me.
It's so much easier said than done.
It's,
it's a,
it's incredibly difficult to stop someone who's really good at something.
If they're really good at,
Oh,
I don't think I'd have a problem.
Joe.
I rented the last 20 seat.
What's the,
uh,
what was we got?
We got to wrap up.
I do it by like an hour here.
So like,
uh,
gimme all,
all things.
Joe Rogan,
uh,
where we can see you.
Any UFC things coming up.
We talked earlier,
there's this
giant giant one,
giant one and Madison Square Garden because the UFC was illegal in New York for
19 years and it was all because of corruption.
This is a funny story.
The Culinary Union,
the guys who used to own the UFC,
they sold the UFC,
but the guys who used to own the UFC also own station casinos,
they own red rocks and they owned a,
a bunch of different casinos.
Like I think 22 separate casinos,
maybe even more.
And all their casinos were nonunion.
And this is a vote by the casino themselves.
Like they got paid well.
And I guess they just decided,
look,
we don't,
we don't need to be union.
So the culinary union was trying to muscle the owners of the UFC into going
union.
And so the way they would do it is,
I mean,
they have a bunch of different things that they do.
They'll stand out and military union on a strong,
they're huge.
They're huge.
And they manage knives.
They managed to keep the UFC out of New York.
And then one of the guys,
it was in their pocket,
got arrested for corruption.
He was the main guy that was keeping in UFC out into New York.
He went down last year at a corruption and right after he went down,
they passed it in New York state because it was passed in every single day.
They told the public that it was all that human cockfighting.
Exactly.
Oh,
they had kickboxing,
boxing,
everything else was legal,
but they wouldn't let the UFC in.
And so finally it's legal now and now that it's legal,
and also there's new owners.
So the Culinary Union doesn't have a beef with these new owners because they
don't even have any casinos.
And the,
the new event that they're gonna put in Madison Square Garden has three world
title fights,
uh,
for former world champions.
Three different fighters were fought for the title before.
I mean,
it's a fucking unbelievably stacked card.
The greatest card and the history was growers fight.
Conor Mcgregor's fighting Eddie Alvarez.
It's the F two,
two.
There's three title fights,
but there's two champions in the,
in the final Conners,
the featherweight champion.
Eddie Alvarez is the lightweight champion.
And if Connor wins,
it'd be the first guy to hold two titles simultaneously in the UFC.
How do you get in that Conor McGregor shape?
Is it too late for me at 48?
No,
no.
You can do it tomorrow.
He's just,
I came home on,
I'm going to give you a pill.
I'm going to give you an that.
I'm going to give you a mindset.
I'm going to teach you the mindset.
You can't just fucking with you.
Thank no.
I thought I had hope.
I had fucking Ho he's getting great shape.
He's like,
dude,
fucking member.
Tommy Hearns.
Like that level shredded with Tommy was like a six foot tall fucking
middleweight.
If somehow we could make like what,
what does middle way one 40.
Well he was one 47 when he fought sugar ray.
Leonard was welterweight and Uncle Ronnie.
Yeah.
Unbelievable.
He was just like,
just like,
it was like you drew them.
Like how do you get that fucking shredded,
that tiny waist and big broad shoulders and they're ridiculous.
Right hand power that reach.
Yeah.
Well when he knocked out,
uh,
Roberto Duran,
that's one of the sick,
it was a hook.
Right?
Uh,
I think it was a right hand.
He face planted them.
I think he hit him with a bunch of things,
but I think he hit him with,
Oh,
you dropped him twice,
but then he face plants and with a right hand were Duran just fell like a tree
like out.
Yes,
exactly.
Like Marquez.
Um,
so I'm Conor McGregor is not in the best shape.
This is what's interesting.
I mean,
he's obviously in great shape,
but he's got a problem with his endurance and it's one of the things that makes
this fight interesting.
Like he got tired.
I heard you saying because he has explosive movements,
he uses up a lot of energy.
He's so fucking fast.
He's so fast and so explosive that when you have that style of fighting,
it's like sprinting.
Whereas Nate Diaz,
the guy who fought was more of like a marathon runner.
Like Nate.
I love Nate.
Nate's awesome.
And so as his brother Nick,
but their style is more like,
they don't go 100% they don't use 100% of their energy with every punch.
They're more like sixties maybe 70% and they're always,
they're always fresh and they do a lot of marathon running.
They do a lot of triathlons and they were always doing endurance work.
So the,
their endurance is a big part of their ability to recover and push a pace that
most people can survive from.
So Connor's is not that guy condoms because he was fighting like Nate Diaz,
like towards the end he did a lot of looking at the clock,
did a lot of running away to kind of reset.
You ran,
literally ran away from home and reset and you know,
it's smart to me once when I first did standup and Steve Sweetie was late and I
was on a material and I just kept looking at the back door,
I was like,
is he coming?
Is he can come in.
I got nothing left.
I remember those
Brockton,
Nick's comedy stop number.
Then you stood up on that.
Like it was like one of those awful stages where it was a really small stage,
like a giant you,
it's like you standing on top of her fucking refrigerator for whatever reason
and you like looking down on the people.
It was almost like this Andy Kaufman,
like talk show desk.
But it was the stage.
I don't know if I did Brockton.
I don't know if I did the cow balloon.
I don't think you were gone by then.
I might've been gone.
I did.
Uh,
I did the,
the Randolph,
I did Brockton Framingham and then,
uh,
I think that was it for the Nixon.
And there was of course,
the one downtown.
I never did Framingham either,
I don't think.
I think that was gone to the moon.
Of course,
the Lawrence did the column and I didn't giggling Mike Clarke's room.
Did you ever do that with giggles on route one and uh,
so anyway,
the Conor McGregor thing,
like he's not,
I would say he's known as one of the best cardio in the world.
You can't say he's not in great shape because he did go five rounds with Nate
Diaz,
but it's just,
it's not,
he's not the same kind of shape that like,
like Nick Diaz has swam from Alcatraz five times.
It gets in the fucking ocean with shark infested northern California.
Water's sweating.
And then you have to be in incredible shape to divvy out of your fucking mind to
that too.
But you gotta be in incredible shape.
I got a buddy of mine,
we just got done running the big foot 200 he ran 204 fucking miles.
205 205 miles in 78 hours.
Three days are running three and a half,
three days in the fucking way.
Yup.
It's called the big foot.
200 tall documents.
It's like running 60 to 70 miles a day.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Be Less than that.
50 or something like that.
Yeah,
something like that.
I remember it.
His number.
Yeah.
Seventies [inaudible] 63 [inaudible] 60 females.
I like what you're saying.
Three trees and I like it.
18 yeah.
He,
um,
he's run hundreds a couple of times.
He actually ran a hundred in June to prepare for the 200 in August.
It's crazy.
So his half marathon is,
is four marathons basically.
Essentially he's a fucking animal.
I mean,
he runs a,
does he,
does he run with those feet sneakers?
No,
we can see the toes now.
He's sponsored by under Armour.
So he wears the under armor,
a fat tire shoes.
It's nice cushioning shoe,
but he's,
um,
he's,
he,
he'll run 1450 miles a day every day.
Who came up with that big foot?
200 savages.
Fucking barbarians.
[inaudible] name's Cameron Hanes.
He's a professional bow hunter.
And,
uh,
to get in shape for bowhunting is bow hunting is all about like climbing up
mountains and shit.
Especially when you're hunting elk.
I hunt with that guy and it's fucking exhausting and I'm in pretty good shape.
I'm not in great shape,
but I'm pretty good shape.
I could barely keep up with them.
I mean barely.
He's barely out of breath and I'm fucking dying.
I'm just drenched in sweat heaving and trying to fall cause like,
well you don't want to bring me alive or anybody else.
I mean the way he does it is a very unique,
when he's like one of the most successful elk hunters in the world and one of
the reasons is is shape because he can get to places like you've seen an elk and
the elk goes over the ridge.
The key is you've got to get to that fucking elk quickly because it's moving
over that Ridge,
right?
So if,
if you look at it,
an l
can,
it goes over the top of a hill and goes to the other side.
The quicker you can get to that,
the closer it's going to be that hill.
You've got to get within 60 yards and you don't know how,
how far it's going to move in the time it takes you to get up there.
Well,
it takes me maybe 10 minutes to get up there.
It'll take him two minutes.
So about those extra eight minutes,
that fucking elks way out of range.
You go down the hill after it,
it's going to see you.
You're never going to get a shot at it.
So he has shot opportunities.
Do you have any like a re like the one that got away sort of shot like you had
it,
you lined it up and whatever.
You exhale at the wrong time and you missed it and then it took off.
That's elk hunting.
I had five of those two weeks ago.
This five of those at least.
Maybe six.
Yeah,
we hunted.
I shot that one with a rifle because we just couldn't get close enough with a
bow and just five.
Do you feel your guide going like,
dude,
are you going to fucking kill one here?
Then what pressure?
Oh,
that's just how it is.
Elk Hunting is hard when you don't,
when you go in earn,
when are you going to go a wild boar hunting again?
I'm going with you.
You and I are going to go,
we're going to schedule something soon.
We'll schedule something.
Let's schedule something like maybe after Christmas.
Yeah,
give me an Uzi and then I'm going to get you a yes.
Ah,
as it comes running.
Cause those things I saw when I'm standing there watching the uh,
the chef there from hell's kitchen.
Um,
ah,
God damn.
And I said his name earlier.
I'm the worst.
Yeah.
Gordon Ramsey.
It made it scrambled eggs again this morning.
My wife fucking loves it.
What kind of Cook?
Scrambled eggs.
Oh Dude.
He fucking,
he puts,
this is what he does.
He,
first of all,
he gets,
he gets the pot,
a little pan going,
a little olive oil,
puts some tomato still on the Vineman name with some mushrooms.
He just lets that fucking sizzle.
And then he takes three eggs and like a dollop of fucking butter puts it in
there.
It doesn't mix.
It already puts it on the flame.
And then he starts mixing this thing around.
He talks about all the chemistry.
You don't want to mix it before you put it in there.
It doesn't put any salt in there.
Cause some reason that does it.
He's like,
oh no,
he's now off to hate you it and you have to cause the hate.
It's in here.
I've watched it a Zillion fucking times when I'm watching the see heats in the
pan hates in the pan.
So that's the one thing that I learned.
Um,
I learned from this guy,
uh,
Sheff,
Roy who did,
who uh,
Roy Choi who started the whole gourmet food truck thing.
I did like five rows doing shooting this thing and I went over there and I got
to sit.
He taught me this shit about the grilled cheese sandwich.
And what I learned about these guys is,
dude,
it's all controlling the heat.
Like my whole shit is just like medium high.
I'm like medium high for 10 minutes and it's like you're not cooking,
you're just standing there like a fucking bouncer.
Assam Shit.
It's like,
so he doesn't manipulate it.
So he does all of that and when it gets to a certain level of a coming together,
then he takes his creme fresh and puts it in there.
What is creme fresh?
I don't know what the fuck it is,
but it's delicious,
right?
And then you get it.
You bring it back back on the heat and then salt in,
right.
He puts that shit in.
You go and you just keep stirring this fucking thing and it almost looks like
it's water.
You don't think it's done.
You taste it.
You're like,
oh my God,
this is great.
Then you take it off,
right?
No Way.
You chop up a little bit of dill,
you sprinkle it up,
you mix it in there,
and then the by then the toast pops
up a little olive oil on that.
He put the fucking scrambled eggs on now with the fucking tomatoes and the
mushroom,
give it to you wife over,
Woo over.
But then they love it and then they keep telling you to make it and you just
can't just do the old scrambled egg with the cheese in it.
I got to get you some eggs.
We have our own chickens.
I have 23 chickens.
How long can they lay eggs before you have to fucking retire them?
Well,
they just stop laying eggs after awhile,
but then,
you know,
I just let them live.
They just,
they just live and then they die.
I've had a bunch just die.
How long,
how long ago?
I've had chickens for now,
I want to say five years.
Somewhere around there.
Four or five years,
maybe five years.
And um,
they just fucking die sometimes.
I've had like a,
but I have some of them that are like five years old,
so there's still five years old.
It's just picture this chicken at his desk,
you know,
this happened,
those plastic 1950s,
you know,
back then when nobody knew shit about fucking heart attacks,
it was terrifying.
What is everybody's,
it's just fucking stop.
And they were all eating bacon and fucking Martinis and all this shit.
They had no idea.
And that was back when the,
you know,
they had no respect for martial arts.
It was all like,
I'll tell you another,
it's stronger than a good old Sunday punch and they'd be sitting there eating
fucking stakes and people would just drop it right and left like dropping dead.
I know you like conspiracy theories.
You look at good conspiracy theory.
It's been like a good one.
The good,
I don't like a real one.
Here's a really once,
he doesn't like being lumped in with people who have silly.
I understand that.
Here's a real proven,
it was in the New York Times.
They proved that scientists were paid off by the sugar industry in the 1960s Oh
yeah,
I have.
Absolutely.
They were paid off to make saturated fat.
The culprit for all these diseases and fat,
fat people and heart attacks when it was actually sugar.
I'm 11 tries to tell him the blame away from sugar and pin it on saturated fat.
So Bailey,
scientists,
bacon is actually not bad for you.
Saturated fat is actually not bad for you.
There's a giant illusion that cholesterol,
everybody thinks to collect.
All your cholesterol is high.
Dietary cholesterol barely moved the needle on blood lipids,
blood lip.
It's like when they measure your diet,
when you're bent,
measure cholesterol in your blood has to do with a lot of,
sounds great to me,
but you're also a standup comedian.
You don't mind,
you don't have a white lab coat on.
I'm sitting here like,
okay,
Doctor Rogan,
you read,
read these things.
But what gives people high cholesterol is first of all the LDL cholesterol,
HDL cholesterol,
the good cholesterol and bad cholesterol,
and you can have high of warm because if you have hired the other one,
it balances each other out.
I'll send you a podcast if you have the fucking the time to listen to it.
It's a SAS sit there long enough.
You Ferret.
It's hard.
It's hard to sit down and listen to this stuff.
But this guy,
Chris crusher was on my podcast who explained it all and scientific.
One of the great names of all the time,
Chris Kresser,
Chris,
Chris Kresser crisscross are coming out on a street smart.
That question question.
Oh um,
but anyway,
it's not cholesterol.
The,
it's,
it's a lot of it is hereditary.
Like if you have high pressure or a dietary cholesterol or high cholesterol.
David Letterman.
Libby didn't have an ounce of fat on him and he needed open heart surgery.
Yes.
Yeah,
yeah.
A lot of that is hereditary.
Some people just get a shit roll the dice,
just like some kids are born with leukemia.
I mean it's just a,
it's not something you did.
It's not like they've been smoking since they were a fetus.
You know what my big fitness thing is?
I'm big,
big time into body weight exercises,
so I'm trying to get myself strong enough to do a front lever it fucking 48
years of a front leaf.
Front lever is basically you hang from the chin up bar,
you bring your legs straight up and you hang in there like a fucking table and
you've got to put party at weight behind the bar.
So there's all of these exercises to explain that.
So just a chat him.
Do you remember planking?
Yes.
Just imagine if he did it on your back.
You're laying on your back in the air,
but you're hanging from the chin up bar and your legs are straight out like
that.
Okay.
Yeah.
So I've been fucking with that full like months trying to build up the strength
and I got myself to the point because the whole thing is you got to be behind
the bar and what's great is I got this big head so it kind of fucking,
you know there's a lot of weight already behind the bar.
Plus I've gotten to a point now where I can actually,
like I used to be almost hanging upside down and then gradually you can kind of
bring you have your legs in a ball.
So like the way it is basically underneath it.
And I've gotten to the point now where I can just start to extend one leg and
then I fall to the ground.
They ain't bad.
I'm going to get there though.
You'll get there.
I just want to bust that out one time cause I've got a buddy of mine,
he has a bet with me that when I'm 70 I can't do 10 pull ups.
So just to fucking Sunday.
No,
when I turned 70 70 to catch the bedding.
Yeah.
As long as you just keep going,
you'll you get,
that's the thing.
It's the loans in the 70s.
Yeah.
But if I don't say he could do 10 pushups,
Chin ups,
if I don't have that bent.
I understand that.
How that fuck you.
So it's a great carrot that I'm chasing that I understand.
Yeah.
You could do that though.
It has nothing to do with age.
You can do that move.
He's going to do a lot.
It doesn't have to do with butter.
Do Bacon and shit.
Linkedin lifting,
uh,
you know,
the best way to do it honestly started doing bodyweight exercises,
do a lot of chin ups and stuff like that,
but do them really slowly.
That's one of the best ways to really develop serious strength.
Like a lot of people like to do chin ups and they like to do those like kipping
Chin ups you see in crossfit.
But what I like to do is what's keeping ego like you kind of like kick up and
you kick up and you're seeing that's like cheating.
It is like cheating,
but it's people who arch their back on the bench press.
But it's a hard workout if you do a bunch of them.
But it's just,
there's a lot of criticism.
Why does crossfit have to be done in front of everybody?
Why can't they just stay in there?
Jim,
why are they always running up and down the street?
Like look at us.
We're working out.
Cause it's like,
look at us,
we're working out.
Should I be more of a charity charge?
Nope.
You should rub it in their face.
They're like vegans and a lot of ways they want you to know what they're doing.
You know?
It's like the like that's the,
that's part of the whole thing.
It's like you become,
there's a whole article about that,
about it's replacing religion for a lot of people who become tribal and you get
involved in these group a like group activities and you,
you identify with that group.
Like you become a crossfitter or you become a Vegan or you become a lot.
I mean,
not there's anything wrong with being either one of those who it was like the
gym is like a garage door is wide open and they're making all this fucking noise
and it's like,
yeah,
I work out too.
You know,
I have the door closed.
I listen to a little iron maiden lately,
but that's part of the fun of it.
They want everybody to know they're doing it.
So you walk by go,
wow bill,
he's in shape and it looks that it looks at him.
He's fucking lifted.
He's doing well.
I've been,
I've been out having breakfast and like outside cafe and all of a sudden
twenties maniacs just run by.
You get to the corner and then they run back the other way.
You just want to fucking throw your pancakes out of.
Well,
it's worse if you're walking and they,
they fucking almost run you over like,
Hey asshole,
this is not a gym.
Okay,
this is a sidewalk.
Like don't,
this is not,
is not a place for you to conduct your class.
Maybe it's like a dream thing.
Like they think the treadmill treadmills take up too much energy.
No,
I think you right.
They want people to know what they're doing and you don't have the space to,
you know,
they don't have a track so they just had to use a sidewalk.
You know?
I've seen that.
I've seen like groups of people run up and down streets.
It's fucking stupid.
I was in Santa Monica,
it was fucking laughing my ass stupid fucking mountains.
But crossfit itself,
what it does is it gets people to get competitive and when they get competitive,
the good thing about it is like there's a bunch of people around you.
You're all pushing each other.
The bad thing about it is a lot of people,
they,
their form falls apart when they start doing high repetitions and they get
competitive with it and then they start getting injured.
I know a lot of fucking people that have hurt themselves doing crossfit,
a lot of bells.
People always fuck themselves up right behind in their baby.
Yeah.
I don't fuck with crap on those.
These are going to do them slowly and doing with correct form.
The beautiful thing about kettle bells as you can get a great workout with a
light Kettlebell,
I could get a great workout with a 35 pound kettle bell is light Kettlebell.
Moving it slowly controlling it and every step of the way.
And you can do all sorts of exercises to go from one to the other,
one to the other and he give you get a full body workout that works.
It,
it's actual functional strength.
Like it'll apply the effluent of even the reservation with the,
I'm going all old school,
I got those atomic holds you like did American Ninja Shit.
Those little fucking look like little cannon balls.
It does a great,
I got those hanging from my ceiling and uh,
I'm trying to get the ones that looked like the num chuck handles and I fucking
went to order the thing and it never came.
And then they sent me an email going like,
Dj,
you still want them?
It's like,
yeah,
I ordered to go to rogue fitness,
rogue fitness.com they have all that crazy.
She got that.
Well that's what I,
I bought my rack through those guys and I got a speed bag and then I'm going to
get those Swedish buys and see if I can get myself up to be able to do a fucking
Cuban flag.
Oh Shit.
Well,
I like the shit lawyer.
I'm working towards something.
I can't just get on an elliptical every day.
Like I'm doing a half hour.
And the big thing is what's my new playlist because I will get bored shitless
with that.
But I feel like with the speed bag,
you know,
I suck at that,
but I'm getting a little bit better at it.
I'm like learning something.
You know,
it's funny,
my wife wanted it.
Um,
it wasn't man enough.
I didn't want to have to think but look at it,
look at it.
Yeah.
It's something cool about doing it.
But do you know,
like Julio,
Cesar Chavez didn't even know how to do that.
It's kind of useless for boxing
and it gives you a little bit of endurance for your shoulders.
But when the fuck is the last time I watched my dream punched somebody like
this.
Imagine someone stood in front of you and you punched him like this.
I think it was to build up your timing.
Then also build up your arms that you could keep your arms up shoulder.
Yeah,
right.
But Julio,
Cesar Chavez,
it's hilarious.
He's one of the greatest boxer of all time.
And he always used to laugh because he would like try to do it and he couldn't
do it.
When you get knocked everybody out in the fucking key,
everybody.
I mean it was a fucking monster.
Listen Dude,
I'm just trying to get into in the,
I used to go to Gleason's gym and,
and they,
and they knew I was there and they used to call me billary swank,
you know,
cause cause a million,
million,
million dollar baby.
It just come out Fillery's Oh no,
we had a great time.
Charlie Murphy once again gave me,
he gave me,
no,
it gave me the lay of the land.
Jolly goes,
you going down eggs.
They,
okay.
He goes,
you're going to be down there about three weeks and did a bad Charlie Murphy.
It goes,
someone's going to come up to you and be like,
Yo,
how long have you been boxing?
nice,
blah,
blah.
Once you get in the ring,
you got to do not get in the ring because he wants to go in there and try out
all the shit that he doesn't have the nerve to try.
Gets a professional fighter and you're going to get fucked up.
Right.
Exactly.
Three weeks,
whatever the fuck he said on the nose,
this fucking,
this guy comes up,
black dude from Brooklyn starts coming to a white guy,
stand up comedian from the suburbs.
Go,
Yo,
your nice man,
you can parks.
I just started laughing.
I got to get the fuck Outta here.
I go,
I'm not getting the ring with you.
When he fucking laughed and walked away and I told Charlie thinking he would
laugh.
You know Charlie's is so fucking real deal.
You just go.
I fucking told you.
It's like I told you,
Charlie Murphy is one of the best guys of all time.
I did that Maxim tour with him.
I got to know him.
We did 22 dates together.
He's a fucking great guy.
I really love that dude.
I really do.
He didn't know one of those guys and my fucking phone went in the toilet.
I lost his fucking number,
so I'm going to be able to call him.
I think I got it.
I'll give it to you.
Okay.
Yeah.
I love that.
All right.
We got to wrap this up,
dude.
I'm sitting like 9 million hours of traffic.
Joe,
you're the fucking best.
You've been one of the top comics for what?
2025 I don't know how many fucking years since I was in Boston when I saw you at
the Kowloon and you did your tigers fucking bit,
which sounds like,
oh,
it's just targets.
Fucking dude.
The dish,
the noise you made of the,
the tiger was fucking unbelievable.
I still remember your bitmaker in front of the chicks out there with the hair
like a giant.
Oh my God.
It was just,
you're a fucking monster,
so I'm so happy for you that you're a,
you got another spa special.
That's out on Netflix.
It's called trigger.
Please watch it.
If you love it,
please rate it.
So,
uh,
you know,
it will stay on the front.
Whatever that fucking scrolly thing is.
And uh,
and that's it man.
I ain't gonna Hook me up with some elk meat.
Fuck you.
Right.
Thanks bill.
I really appreciate it.
Yeah,
no worries.
No worries.
Still the same way about you man.
You're one of my all time favorite.
We're going to have a big hug afterwards.
All right guys,
thanks for listening.
All right,
what's up bill borough here.
how great was that?
Ah,
the Great Joe Rogan finally got him on after nine years of doing my fucking
podcast.
Finally got him on.
Um,
and I didn't do any of the advertising because I knew that it was going to be
too interesting to sit there and talk to that guy.
So he has a little bit of advertising.
I what you're thinking.
Oh
Shit.
Build a fucking advertising.
That's boring.
Well not the way I do it.
All right,
here we go.
We got a new one here.
See Souls.
See so see,
so see,
so there you go.
Fuck you man.
All right.
See,
so is the place for comedy.
They won't tell you how amazing they are,
but I will evidently see.
So is amazing.
It's comedy for comedy nerds by comedy nerds,
CSO,
spelled c.
So s e s o is the new ad free streaming service bringing you hilarious original
specials,
handpicked classics,
weeks of standards.
You better not fucking have mine on there and not pay me.
You [inaudible] hand up picks,
pick classics,
weeks of standup specials and more,
uh,
bingeable economy,
comedy anytime,
any way.
CSO,
uh,
every episode of SNL ever.
Really,
Jesus,
this is a big fucking thing.
Cause those guys,
those guys hoard those specials,
um,
those episodes including new episodes the day after they air the tonight show
starring Jimmy Fallon,
Jimmy Fallon from New England.
Oh,
you did so great.
Um,
and late night with Seth Meyers,
the day after they air and they even have classics like 30 rock parks and
recreation and saved by the bell.
Um,
and those are already classics.
He's,
he saved by the bell.
Even British comedies like the original office with that dangerous guy,
Ricky Gervais saw what's he going to do with the MEC.
He's breaking up bear
the entire money python catalog,
the it crowd and Steve Coogan as Alan Partridge discover the next big names in
comedy and watched the icons before they made it before they made it big like
Louis C K Chelsea Peretti,
Amy Schumer,
Bo Burnham,
and so much more critically acclaimed originals and exclusive content like
harmonquest created by comedian Dan Harmon and funny as hell a variety show
featuring such comedians as Jim Jefferies.
Ah,
Jim Jefferies and Hannibal Burress.
Um,
if you're serious about comedy,
you got to go to seeso streaming.
Anytime Jesus fucking Christ,
we get it.
CSO is ad free and it's just 399 a month.
That's less than you paid for the Latte or artists and cold brew coffee you're
holding right now.
And right now my listeners can try see,
so a free for two months.
When you use Promo code bird at the checkout,
at ain't point they're going to say what CSO stands for c.
So I'm seriously ignorance,
Ego,
thugging Oscars.
I don't fucking know.
It shows what you can get in shows.
You can't get anywhere else from critically acclaimed original series to all 40
plus years of SNL CSOS,
the only place that offers every episode ever made and the new episodes the day
after they air.
Just go to [inaudible] dot com right now to sign up for two months for free,
for Promo with the Promo Code [inaudible] at checkout.
That's seeso.com Promo Code Burr to just for the fucking SNL alone.
That's great.
Um,
all right.
Hey,
speaking to Joe Rogan,
his,
his company on it,
on it has a new product.
It's called emulsified MCT oil.
What the fuck is that?
Well,
we're going to tell you MCT oil is one of the fastest sources of clean fuel for
the body and the brain.
It's one of the best ways to power up your performance and kickstart a weight
management program.
And I should do that.
Rub it right on my stomach.
Uh,
there are a lot of MCT oil brands out there,
but none.
There is none like the emulsified MCT oil from Onnit.
What's emulsification.
That's like when you got Balsamic vinegarette just sitting there,
okay.
In the fucking vinegarette goes away from the Balsamic or vice versa,
whatever,
and then you fucking shit up and all of a sudden it's been combined.
It's been a mulcify it you get it.
It's like a carburetor when you got the air and the fuel mixture and it creates
that foam that she can't drink,
but it looks like a latte.
That's some off suffocation.
Emulsification available in three delicious flavors.
Coconut,
Vanilla and strawberry.
Jesus Christ,
that's me right there.
Coconut head,
vanillas skin,
strawberry,
pubes emulsified MCT oil mixes like a cream easily in your morning.
Coffee without the need for a blog.
No mess,
no cleanup.
You can even mix it into your favorite food.
Liquid Billy red face right here from on it right now.
If you go to [inaudible] dot com o n n I t.com/ [inaudible] you can get on,
it's emulsified MCT oil for 12% off.
That's on an o and n I t.com/bird.
Again,
emulsified MCT oil for 12% off any and for any reason.
If you don't like it,
they'll give you money back.
No questions asked.
You got nothing to lose.
Go to [inaudible] dot com slash burn now and get a and get on it.
Okay,
hold on.
I gotta left.
Jesus Christ.
They get out of breath from reading out loud.
That's how dumb I am.
All right,
seat Geek.
Okay.
Buying tickets online for sports and concerts has been a confusing process for a
long time.
Now there's nothing confusing about it.
It cost a fucking fortune.
Um,
it's always hard to find the best deal for that game or show you want to go to
and none of those older tickets sites want to change that.
But see geek is different.
They've come along and create an amazing APP and website that makes it easier
than ever.
Then Abba for fans to buy and sell tickets.
Seek does all the price comparisons for you by searching multiple tickets sites
and ensuring that you get the best possible deal and seek wants to help you get
the best move,
the best bang for your buck.
That's why even ticket.
That's why every ticket on Siki is given a grade based on value.
You'll immediately see any underpriced seats and be able to find the best deals
that fit your budget.
Best of all,
my listeners get $20 $20 rebate off their first SeatGeek purchase to get your
$20 rebate on tickets.
How do I do that,
man?
Download the seat Geek App.
Go to the settings tab and click add and add a promo code.
Enter the Promo Code Berbee you are seek.
We'll send you $20 off after you've made your first ticket purchase.
Download the SEATGEEK APP and enter the Promo Code bird today.
Jesus,
I was doing all right there.
Oh Jesus.
Here we go.
Our old friends here.
Everybody here,
they are returning.
Once again.
Bowl,
zip.
Are you hiring?
Do you know where to post your job to find the best candidates?
Posting your job in one place ad isn't enough to find quality candidates.
What do I do?
Man?
If you want to find the perfect hire,
you need to post your job on all the top job sites.
Is it hard?
No,
it's easy with all fucking Zip,
right?
[inaudible] dot com you can post your job to 100 plus job sites including social
media networks like the Facebook,
like the Twitter,
all with one single click there,
find candidate and kind of candidate in any city or any industry.
What?
Find candidates in any city or industry nationwide.
Just post once and watch your qualified candidates roll in like all ad hoc,
ported into down here in Florida to zip recruiter's,
easy to use interface,
no juggling emails,
no juggling emails or calls to your office.
Quickly screen candidates,
rate them and hire the right person fast.
Find out today why zip.com has been used over one by over 1 million businesses
and right now you my listeners,
my listeners can post jobs on zip,
Rick [inaudible]
for a free by going free by going to ziprecruiter.com/per that's
ziprecruiter.com/bar one more time to get free.
Go to set
Rick
third.com/
[inaudible] all right,
next one,
last and final.
Sorry,
that's getting them noxious.
I know,
but there's only so many with different ways to read.
All right.
Oh Jesus.
It's track.
We're all loses.
Newsweek reports.
The average American wastes 55 minutes a day looking for things they owned but
can't find.
Share a story when you've lost something you needed.
Yeah,
I lost my soul when I fucking do something like that.
Just give me the copy and I'll fucking read it.
Oh yeah.
I remember the time.
I couldn't find my mittens.
Oh boy.
You know we had a snowball fight coming up.
I get it.
You put this fucking thing on shit.
You don't lose it anymore yet.
For some reason they're going to write 10 pages is shit.
Tracker makes losing things a thing of the past and I'll tell you how to get one
for free in a minute.
Tracker was a coin size device that locates misplaced keys,
wallets,
bags,
computers,
dildos,
anything in seconds.
Just pair tracker to your smart phone,
attach it to anything and find his precise location with a tap of a button.
It's that easy.
Lose your phone,
press a button.
Ah,
there it is on track or your phone rings even when it's on silent.
Grapey tracker is finding over a million.
Jesus Christ.
Cleal could you go take a fucking fleet bath?
You've been shaken and storing the whole fucking time was supposed to be,
oh,
don't look at me like that.
Come here buddy.
Come here.
I'm sorry.
You just look at me like,
dude,
I will fucking rip your throat out if I want to.
Now it's up on the couch.
That's all.
Didn't want it.
Good.
All right.
Tracker is um,
what am I tracker is finding over a million misplaced items each day.
Order yours and never lose anything.
Again,
listen to the show.
Get a free tracker.
Bravo with any order,
go to the t h e tracker.com and enter Promo Code [inaudible].
The hardest thing you'll ever have to find is their website.
Go to tracker.com right now and enter the Promo code birth for free tracker.
What?
Free tracker.
Bravo with any order.
Uh,
again,
that's tracker.com Promo Code Burr.
Did anybody see that fucking ad on TV that was making fun of uh,
Ohio state the way they go.
D,
Ohio State University.
They were talking about things that you,
that you're sick up.
They go,
are you sick of dramatic pauses after football players?
Say the name of their university.
And they had this guy like doing like cross side and he just went like the
Brockton community college.
I butchered it,
but you got to see it.
The guy's performance on it is tremendous.
It's as funny as how unfunny the way I just did it.
Look at you.
[inaudible].
What are you doing?
Hmm?
You want to go outside?
Cleo?
Can I get it at a high with before we leave clear.
Go get off the couch.
Get off the couch.
All right,
here we go.
The key is you just have to make eye contact.
I'm going to go for this.
Cleo,
do you want to go outside?
Cleo?
Okay.
Oh,
there.
Yeah.
Go.
Good girl.
All right,
I'll talk to you later.